ja wir haben es nun schon mehrmals
angesprochen in dieser sendung im
bundestag und im bundesrat steht also
das neue infektionsschutzgesetz heute
zur abstimmung an und deshalb gebe ich
jetzt sehr gern ab nach berlin an
joachim von fallois der sich
interessante gesprächsgäste an seine
seite geholt kataloge
hallo ja so ist es meine damen und
herren zunächst wird der bundestag in
zweiter und dritter lesung hier
entscheiden über die novelle des
infektionsschutzgesetzes und dann geht
es rüber in den bundesrat und sie haben
gerade die massive kritik der
ministerpräsidenten was die hotspot
regelung vor allen dingen angeht ja
schon mitbekommen die
ministerpräsidenten das ist kein
geheimnis werden aber dennoch heute hier
im bundesrat gegenüber muss ich sagen
ich stehe im bundestag werden doch mit
stimmen denn sonst ist es ein
einspruchsgesetz müsste man den
vermittlungsausschuss dort anrufen und
dann würde das ganze so lange dauern
dass die übergangsregelungen die die
meisten länder ziehen wollen bis zum
zweiten april gar nicht mehr ziehen
würde alles ein wenig kompliziert zum
glück gibt es ja fachleute die sich da
sehr gut auskennen ich habe mir
eingeladen die beiden
gesundheitspolitischen sprecher der fdp
und der cdu csu christine
aschenberg-dugnus für die fdp und tino
sorge für die union frank luck los es
ist ja kein geheimnis die fdp hat dieses
gesetz eigentlich auch so ein bisschen
gegen die widerstände der
koalitionspartner in der ampel mit
durchgesetzt ich darf daran erinnern
dass die spd vorsitzende am mittwoch
noch gesagt hat sie würde sich wünschen
dass die masken pflicht auch allgemein
in räumlichkeiten gilt und herr damen
das ist der gesundheitspolitische
experte der grünen sagt das ist
eigentlich ein must-have dass wir das
auch in diesem gesetz verankern nun gab
es ja noch mal sitzungen was ist denn
geändert worden in diesen sitzung ist
die masken pflicht in räumlichkeiten mit
enthalten sowie dass auch menschen der
spd und nicht unwichtige der grünen
wollen nein das nicht aber wir haben zum
beispiel die masken pflicht in
arztpraxen reingebracht also überall
dort wo vulnerable gruppen sind da haben
wir nach gebessert aber wenn ich ihnen
sagen die allgemeine masken pflicht
würde ja bedeuten dass wir auch gerade
in schulen und kitas die masken pflicht
beibehalten sollten oder müssten und da
sind wir strikt dagegen und da sind wir
uns einig mit vielen kinderpsychologen
in den ärzten mit fachleuten die sagen
das geht nicht denn omikron ist zwar
hoch ansteckend hat aber auch gerade bei
kindern ein sehr sehr milden verlauf und
insofern müssen wir schon
berücksichtigen was wir unseren kindern
antun sie sind schlechter beim lesen das
haben wir gerade jetzt festgestellt sie
haben psychische probleme und da müssen
wir noch mal genau hinschauen was wir
damit erreichen und deswegen haben wir
gesagt die wohl der rebellengruppen da
ist die masken pflicht wichtig aber in
anderen bereichen müssen wir sie
aufheben britta ernst das ist die
bildungsministerin aus brandenburg und
gleichzeitig die ehefrau des herrn
bundeskanzlers die hat gesagt sie wird
auf jeden fall bis zum zweiten april
gerade die masken pflicht auch bei den
kindern neben den schulen durchsetzen
denn nur die maske hilft gegen
ansteckungen herr sorge scheint doch
nicht so ganz einheitlich in der ampel
oder ein kunde ist genau das das problem
dass man zwar mit unterschiedlichen
auffassungen sagen kann wir sind für
lockerungen oder wir sind im team
vorsicht aber das was jetzt passiert ist
eben ein mix aus beiden und das erzeugt
wird und wenn ich dann höre dass er
jetzt nachgebessert wurden arztpraxen
sind jetzt beispielsweise enthalten
zahnarztpraxen sind wieder nicht drin
physiotherapiepraxen sind auch nicht mit
enthalten also dann zeigt das dass wir
hier tatsächlich ein bürger erzeugen und
ich glaube es ist ja nur um das alle
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten der länder in der
mpk unisono sagen so geht das nicht das
wird dem nicht gerecht was wir wollen
als einen basisschutz ein
instrumentenkasten pandemie auch wenn
sie es verschlechtern sollte weiter
bekämpfen zu können und ich glaube das
sollte man als regierung aus sehr ernst
nehmen ja auch die virologen viele
virologen zumindest kritisieren dieses
gesetz michael stormann sagt zum
beispiel das aktuelle
infektionsgeschehen heute wieder ein top
wert wird von dieser ampel gar nicht
mehr zur kenntnis genommen
offensichtlich nicht mehr als maßstab
genommen sondern es geht eigentlich nur
um schneller schneller erleichterung und
lockerungen die infektionszahlen sollten
ja eigentlich schon lange nicht mehr der
maßstab sein wir waren uns von anfang an
einig dass wir eine überlastung der
intensivstation verhindern und durch
omikron haben wir eine andere situation
natürlich haben wir hohe
infektionszahlen aber schauen sie sich
mal an die intensivstationen heute zb
wieder immer jeden tag werden sie
weniger belegt und das zeigt doch dass
wir auch wieder lockerungen vornehmen
müssen und zwar in dem maße wie es
verantwortbar ist und wir sind der
meinung es ist verantwortbar in dem maße
weil wir eben vulnerable gruppen weiter
schützen auch mit was masten pflichten
und ansonsten wir verbieten ja nicht die
masken ich bin ein großer befürworter
der masken aber uns wird omicron noch
sehr sehr lange beschäftigen die
nächsten jahre wir müssen auch die
eigenverantwortung der menschen stärken
und jeder kann für sich selbst auch
entscheiden ob er in bestimmten
situationen abstand halten und maske
tragen sollte ich werbe dafür aber das
kann man doch selbst entscheiden und
bitte nicht den kindern weiter diese
masken pflicht aufoktroyieren die
negativen auswirkungen sind so immens
das können wir nicht weiter so
fortführen da würde ich ihnen gerne
vorlesen eine studie des max planck
institutes die hat nämlich untersucht
ft2 masken gesunde und ein infizierter
in einem raum da ist die
ansteckungsgefahren 0,1 prozent nach 20
minuten wenn zwei personen keine maske
tragen ist schon nach wenigen minuten
die andere person auch infiziert also
man kann ja nicht einfach sagen die
maske bringt nichts auch bei kindern
nicht ich glaube ich habe mich
missverstanden ich habe niemals gesagt
die maske bringt nichts ich habe gerade
eben betont sie bringt sehr viel aber
sie können noch eigenverantwortlich die
maske tragen und wenn sie bei kindern so
negative auswirkungen hat sämtliche
kinderärzte und psychologen sagen kinder
brauchen auch um lesen zu lernen um
soziales verhalten zu haben müssen sie
die mimik sehen im gesicht das haben sie
jetzt seit zwei jahren nicht und das
müssen wir ändern weil bei kindern hat
omikron eben ein sehr sehr milden
verlauf noch milder als bei jungen
erwachsenen
und da müssen wir schauen wo ist da die
linie die wir halten müssen ich verstehe
das argument meine kinder sind schon aus
dem haus ich habe großes verständnis für
kinder und ihre schwierigkeiten in
dieser phase herr sorge und dennoch ist
es ja so im herbst haben wir das gesehen
dass gerade durch die schulkinder auch
bei uns im team die mütter wurden krank
die väter auch die kleine kinder hatten
weil da wird sich natürlich weiter
gegeben werden grunde ist das ja nur ein
teilbereich den wir diskutieren das was
das gesetz leider nicht erfüllt ist eine
klarheit also das gesetz ist ein
einziger unbestimmter rechtsbegriff wir
haben ja bei der frage beispielsweise
wann brauchen wir auch für schärfung bei
der masken pflicht wieder stichwort wenn
eine neue virusvariante auftritt der
wird im gesetz definiert wenn eine
höhere pathogenität ist also höhere
krankheitslast das wird nicht klar
definieren also keiner weiß wie das
konkret vor ort ausgelegt werden soll da
gibt es ja auch im dissens zwischen
bundesjustizminister der genau sagt das
ist anders verstehen als der
bundesgesundheitsminister wir haben das
problem bei der frage der hotspots
regelung das heißt was kann ein hotspot
sein wir haben das bei der frage
drohende krankenhaus überlassung also
das sind viele dinge einfach überhaupt
nicht geklärt da gibt es viel spielraum
und das ist ja auch das was wir und
union und die länder kritisieren dass
ich sagen der basisschutz der
werkzeugkasten um eben schnell reagieren
zu können also beispielsweise auch in
innenräumen wenn sich die infektions
lage verschärft der wird mit diesem
gesetz nicht erreicht und deshalb kann
man wirklich nur sagen der gesetzentwurf
das sagen wir auch schon die kolleginnen
und kollegen aus den ländern der muss
nachgebessert werden und das noch vor
der verabschiedung das ist glaube ich
ein warnsignal an die regierungen das
sollte man ernst dem frau schnell
drücken was ich fange mal ganz
grundsätzlich an die wenn die
hospitalisierung nicht mehr der maßstab
ihres gesetzes ist welche maßstäbe legen
sie denn dann an ich habe gesagt die
hospitalisierung also die zahl
derjenigen menschen die auf
intensivstationen liegen das ist der
maßstab den wir wollen ja die
überlastung des gesundheitswesens
reduzieren beziehungsweise gar nicht
erst aufkommen lassen insofern ist die
inzidenz also die infektionszahlen ist
nicht der maßstab da waren wir
eigentlich schon vor monaten so weit
dass wir das wussten jetzt wird
komischerweise immer nur auf die
inzidenz zahlen geschaut das hat heute
zum beispiel auch der vorsitzende des
hausärzteverbandes herr weigelt
kritisiert der sagte wir zwitschern
immer von den verschiedenen systemen hin
und her mal geht es um die inzidenz mal
geht es um die zahl der
intensivpatienten das verwirrt die
menschen auch ich bin der meinung und
mit vielen experten und schon seit
monaten dass die zahl der intensiv
medizinisch behandelten das kriterium
ist und die steigt nicht trotz der hohen
infektionszahlen aschenberg dugnus was
fällt sind die leute die sich um diese
intensiv patienten kümmern können und da
gab es gestern bei den
ministerpräsidenten auch schon
interessante diskussion ob zum beispiel
demnächst pfleger und krankenschwestern
die erkrankt sind
aber keine symptome mehr zeigen ob die
nicht gleich dann wieder in den dienst
gehen können ja natürlich ist jetzt
durch diese hohe infektionszahlen sind
viele ausfälle in den bereichen aber sie
müssen ja auch sagen wer doppelt geimpft
und gepustet ist überträgt das virus ja
auch eine ganz kurze zeit nur und ist
auch vor einem schweren verlauf
geschützt deswegen haben wir ja auch für
impfungen und mustern aber
selbstverständlich ist es bei der
kritischen infrastruktur so dass durch
die infektionen da auch ausfälle sind
und entsprechend muss man dann reagieren
aber wir müssen doch jetzt nicht
sämtliche maßnahmen verschärfen weil das
bringt in dem fall ja nichts sie wissen
ja dass sehr viele doppelt geimpft und
gewusst hätte auch an omikron erkranken
ja und das ist ja das verwirrende am
anfang hat man gedacht ich lass mich
jetzt impfen ich lasse mich boostern
alles wird gut und das ist ja leider gar
nicht so nochmal was wirklich schützt
das zeigt zum beispiel auch das
geschehen karneval in köln kann man gut
nachweisen was wirklich schützt wären
masken denn da ist die inzidenz riesig
hoch gegangen obwohl alle leute die in
den kneipen gefeiert haben mindestens
geimpft oder gepustet waren ist die
instanz riesig explodiert also noch mal
impfen und mustern ist eigentlich keine
lösung für die menschen die sich auf
keinen fall anstecken dürfen nämlich die
berühmten wohlhabenden gruppen die die
fdp eigentlich mal in altersheime und
krankenhäuser verband dabei laufen
tausende durch die gegend die zum
beispiel krebs infiziert sind ich selber
bin schwerer asthmatiker bin gut
eingestellt aber ich möchte es nicht
fliegen also im grunde ist das genau der
punkt dass man einerseits sagt wir
müssen stärker auf eigenverantwortung
setzen aber in den bereichen in rom
haben sie angesprochen oder da wo
honorable gruppen auch zusammenkommen
dass man da durchaus über solche
maßnahmen nachdenken muss aber was wir
tatsächlich was wir tatsächlich
kritisieren ist die frage wie können
diese massnahme angeordnet werden und
das ist ja im gesetz so unklar geregelt
also besteht ja auch noch der streit in
wie weit können die länder das anordnen
also die landesparlamente sollen jetzt
solche massnahmen anordnen also muss das
parlament im land jetzt jede einzelne
maßnahme anordnung also ist es viel zu
unklar diffus und insofern glaube ich
auch sollten wir uns auch an anderen
ländern mal ein beispiel wenn ich mir
angucke nicht weiß österreich einfach
alle kann vielleicht genau das sagen im
grünen bereich also stichwort
pflegeheime beispielsweise in den
straßenbahnen also da wo viele menschen
aufeinander treffen masken pflicht ja
auch unter berücksichtung der inzidenz
werte und krankenhaus auslastung aber
darüber hinaus klare regelungen wenn
sich lage verschärft muss man dann
reagieren können genau das steht doch in
unserem infektionsschutzgesetz jetzt
drin dass die wohlhabenden gruppen eine
maske nicht haben oder zum beispiel auch
testen können auch in kitas und in
schulen das ist doch gerade der bereich
der geschützt und alle moment alle das
europäische ausland ich kann ihnen die
ganzen länder aufzählen die haben alle
keine masken pflicht mehrere habe ohne
also aus ausnahme ist der pnv in der
schweiz und auch da haben wir eine maske
pflicht also genau das was er sorge eben
angemahnt hat genau das setzen wir
gerade um aber frei schmeckt und es
kommen wir noch mal auf die wollen raten
gruppen noch mal die sind ja nicht
weggeschlossen die bewegen sich in
unserer gesellschaft zum beispiel in
geschäften und sie sagen in geschäften
soll keine maske mehr getragen werden
und der bundeswehr
bundesgesundheitsminister gestern im zdf
noch mal betont er rechnet mit einer
wesentlich höheren infektionszahlen im
sommer als es zum beispiel im letzten
jahr der fall war das ist doch einfach
unverantwortlich gegenüber den
vulnerable in gruppen die gerade sie von
der fdp mann schützen war ja die wollen
wir auch schützen deswegen machen wir es
ja dort wo die sich nicht selbst
schützen können per gesetz aber dort wo
man sich selbst schützen kann mit so
einer fft zwei maske sind sie wenn sie
richtig tragen geschützt und ich weiß es
genau aus den einzelnen kommunen es gibt
wunderbare projekte wenn sie zum
beispiel einen bereich wo viele ältere
menschen sind da gibt es spezielle
einkaufszeiten in den
lebensmittelgeschäften vertrauen wir
doch auch mal auf die kreativität der
bürgerinnen und bürger vertrauen wir
doch auch mal darauf dass sie sich
richtig verhalten nach zwei jahren
pandemie und nicht immer nur
staatlicherseits alles vorschreiben ich
glaube die menschen wissen am besten wie
sie sich zu schützen haben versorge
gucken wir noch mal ganz schnell auf das
verfahren hervor gestern die erste
lesung heute die zweite dritte gestern
die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hat die
fdp in oppositionszeiten ja immer
kritisiert dass die regierung sich mit
den ministerpräsidenten reinigt und ich
hab so ein bisschen das gefühl dass die
ampel in dem fall der
bundesjustizminister gesagt jetzt machen
was man genau umgekehrt was bedeutet das
denn unterm strich die
ministerpräsidenten müssen das gesetz
durchführen in ihren die maßstäbe sind
unklar sie haben schon zwei mal
angesprochen und vor allem können sie
heute im bundesrat im grunde genommen
gar nicht ablehnen was heißt denn das
für das demokratische zusammenspiel
zwischen bund und ländern aber ich finde
es ist ein tiefpunkt im
parlamentarischen zusammenspiel das muss
man sagen wir haben ja nicht nur diese
enge beratungs folge sondern werden
haben wir hatten ja auch das novum dass
wir die anhörung zu diesem gesetz noch
vor der ersten lesung gemacht haben also
normalerweise hat man erste lesung dann
geht es in die anhörung dann kommen zwei
der dritte lösung und das jetzt so
schnell entschieden werden muss das
kommt ja mit ansage also seit monaten
ist klar dass ab dem 19 ab dem 20 märz
die maßnahmen auslaufen wenn es keine
neuregelung gibt oder verlängerung das
wusste die ampelkoalition sie haben
nichts getan und jetzt haben wir das
problem dass die ministerpräsident mehr
oder weniger sagen friss oder stirb das
heißt sie haben vorhin angesprochen wenn
nicht zugestimmt wird heute im bundesrat
dann gibt es ein noch größeres war
deshalb kann man sagen na ja es ist
schlecht gemacht das gesetz
handwerkliche mängel zu vage aber es ist
besser als gar nichts aber das kann
natürlich nicht sinn und zweck der
ganzen parlamentarischen übungen seien
frauen - um den armen zu schließen sie
haben das angesprochene europäischen
ausland wird auch so verfahren das würde
ja bedeuten in der diskussion die wir
auch haben um eine impfpflicht in
deutschland kann auf keinen fall eine
impfpflicht kommen denn die meisten
länder im europäischen ausland haben
kann neben pflichten und weiß ich dass
sie auch nicht in der pflicht sind aber
die mehrheit ihrer ampel kollegen ja zum
beispiel und kolleginnen also das
argument ist auch übrigens ich als vater
haben dass in der erziehung auch nie
benutzt nur weil andere etwas machen
mache ich es auch das finde ich ein
recht schwaches argument nein das ist ja
auch nicht das argument ich bin gegen
eine impfpflicht aber dafür dass die
menschen dazu gebracht werden sich
impfen zu lassen und zwar durch
aufklärung und wir wissen es wir haben
nicht nur die impfgegner wir haben viele
menschen die angst haben vor der impfung
den kann man die ängste nehmen und wir
werben ja für das impfen aber durch
zwang sehen wer ist es nicht umsetzbar
und wir tun immer alle so wenn wir die
impfpflicht hätten werden sofort alle
geimpft stimmt ja nicht und die
maßnahmen die dazu führen sind alle
nicht durchdacht vielen dank dass die
beiden da waren drin geht es nämlich los
und den vorsitz hatte petra pau neben
katrin göring eckardt die einst hier
bundestags-vizepräsidentin die hier den
dienst versehen kann seit zwei tagen die
anderen sind mich erkrankt die meisten
von den anderen an und ich gebe rein